i don't believe this is a law
enforcement
issue we are so busy uh enforcing
and keeping our citizens safe by
arresting robbers and child molesters
and
home burglars that making criminals out
of normally law abiding citizens doesn't
make sense
that was fresno county california's
sheriff on this program yesterday
she joined several other sheriffs across
the country who are
refusing to enforce enforce coveted
restrictions like lockdowns and curfews
this holiday season
tom holman joining us now a former
acting director of ice and a fox news
contributor
tom good morning thanks thanks for being
here this morning do you agree with that
the sheriff's going at it on their own
and saying we're not going to enforce
this
absolutely i think they're great
american patriots they understand that
law by u.s citizens have first amendment
rights too
you know these governors these
democratic governors they think that
protesters
protests that turn violent and tell the
police to turn a blind eye because
they have perseverant rights to gather
and petition the government
they have that right but law abiding
citizens don't have a first amendment
right to go to church
or have family gatherings i think these
sheriffs are american patriots
and they're following the u.s
constitution god bless them so weigh
in on the broader problem right now
we've got
a rising infection rate happening across
the country uh obviously and we've
we've got hospitalization rate that is
going up as well deaths are climbing in
numbers there's obviously a huge problem
still with this pandemic in covet 19 in
this country
so many of these local municipalities
are trying to do their best to enforce
restrictions to stop the spread you may
agree with them or not agree with them
but then weigh in on it how should this
be handled
no i look i think the cdc made it clear
i think i think wearing masks
when it's appropriate is the right thing
to do i think social distancing when
appropriate's the right thing to do
but a governor can't legislate a law on
his own
none of these what the governors have
done of these lockdowns they haven't
passed any law there's no law
that's been enacted by legislature they
just they just
decided to make a decision and they want
law enforcement out of their local law
enforcement out there to enforce a
non-law against u.s citizens at the same
time
they refuse to let the same law
enforcement officers work with ice
to arrest criminals and public safety
threats off their streets or other jail
which is their job to keep criminals
locked to keep criminals locked up and
keep our
our streets safe they refuse that it's
it's it's hypocrisy
that law enforcement can't do their job
and rest protesters to commit crimes
or work with ice to take criminals
public safety threats off the street
that's a no-go for these democratic
governors but
if they can't have it both ways they
can't say one forces not law against
law-abiding citizens
and at the same time ignore criminal
statute that actually was legislated
by a law enforcement a law body either
congress or their state legislator
okay so as you well know governor andrew
cuomo here in new york does not agree
with you listen
how a law enforcement officer says
i choose not to enforce that law
i believe that law enforcement officer
violates
his or her constitutional duty that's
not a law enforcement officer
that's a dictator
so you're not a law enforcement officer
you can't pick and choose uh and
if that's the way you run your law
enforcement agency i don't consider it a
law enforcement agency
if these sheriffs don't abide the many
of them who have said that
tom could they be held responsible then
by governors like
andrew cuomo well first of all let's be
clear governor cuomo is is
stating misfacts here he's lying to his
people
there is no law no law was in enacted by
his state legislature this is if
anybody's a dictator it's him by pushing
down
this executive order without any input
and second of all i say this i'll say
the same thing to uh governor cuomo that
i said
representative jay paul during my last
hearing i i paid a lot of taxes in new
york now because i own property new york
he works for me he works for the new
york state taxpayers
he's accountable to us not the other way
around we're not accountable to him
so to hindu vilified law enforcement for
some protecting the first amendment
rights
for new york state residents is is
abhorrent
it just it's insulting some of the
restrictions though because the
the quarantine restrictions that he has
put in place for his state which are
very strict and much stricter than
the many other states and have been for
quite some time that was issued by
executive order
yeah i get that but the state
legislature has not enacted any laws in
the state of new york
look the problem is it's inconsistent
across the country
but new york state governor cuomo has
been vilifying law enforcement for years
it isn't just this cobit thing that now
he attacks law enforcement he's been
attacking ice officers he's compared
them to
the the gangsters on the street he won't
he won't allow law enforcement officers
in new york to work with ice
he in in him and along with the mayor
new york city de blasio
has knocked ice out of the rikers island
jail which
releases gang members and significant
criminals every day
so let's not get things mixed up with
governor cuomo he's been against law
enforcement
from day one he's been he's been
vilifying them for a couple years this
is just his latest
his latest argument and why law
enforcement is less
than they used to be okay so let me ask
you a question as
we listen to what you're saying and take
that in and we've heard what the
governor has to say and some of these
other democratic governors across the
country who have very
tough restrictions on their people you
see
and you say that you you you believe the
cdc and the science and it says to wear
a mask social distance
if that isn't going on and that
certainly isn't going on in some areas
of this country we don't like to think
so but it is
so should something be done at a local
or state level to help enforce
some of the things that we know
significantly slow or stop the spread of
this virus should anything be done to
enforce that
maybe the state officials can enforce
well he's asking
someone to do he's asking local law
enforcement to enforce something that
isn't a law
and if he wants to send down executive
order then hold your state agencies
responsible
for overseeing that but you can't tell
the local law enforcement
enforce a non-law that nothing a law
that hasn't been enacted
by by by any state legislature and
attack law-abiding citizens
and their first amendment rights while
at the same time telling those same law
enforcement agencies
you're not allowed to arrest protesters
to commit crimes you're not allowed to
take criminals off the street with
assistance advice
you can't have it both ways yeah i mean
there was this
large jewish wedding thousands of people
he's warning legal action
against things like that and this is
what's happening and this is what a lot
of these states are facing right now
as we all try to we all try to do the
right thing and people have different
ways of doing it
tom great to have you on this morning
did you have a final thought
no i think at some point sandra we get
we need to trust american people to do
the right thing
i mean we the american people know
there's the covet 19 don't
i'm not belittling this this is this is
a significant issue we're dealing with
hundreds of thousands have died it's
serious but at some point you gotta let
the american people
take control their lives and and most
americans
most citizens will do the right thing
and for those that don't will hold them
accountable but you can't
hold you can't violate their first
amendment rights too knowingly
violate their first first amendment
rights while protecting the first
amendment rights for people that are out
there
committing crimes it's it's just it's
not the way this country is supposed to
be
all right we appreciate your time this
morning tom thank you